ce sont ce sont des affirmations
premièrement du commandant Alexandre
tarnanski le commandant du secteur
militaire de tabria qui affirme que la
Russie aurait utilisé des armes
chimiques le 6 août contre l'armée
ukrainienne vers dans le secteur de novo
danilifca c'est dans la région de
zaporigia il y aurait eu deux salves de
roquettes lancées de de d'obus lancé
contre les troupes ukrainiennes qui
contenait un élément chimique alors
supposément une substance chimique qui
s'appelle chloropistine qui a été
développée par les forces russes par la
Russie pour l'utiliser comme un gaz
lacrymogène un gaz chimique dans les
tranchées de la Première Guerre mondiale
sauf que la Russie est bien elle a signé
la Convention contre l'utilisation des
armes chimiques en
1993 donc elle n'est supposée ni
posséder ni développer et encore moins
utilisé
au hasard sur le champ de bataille c'est
interdit par les conventions
internationales donc ce n'est pas la
première fois comme vous le mentionnez
que l'Ukraine que l'Ukraine affirme que
de tels arbres ont été utilisées sur son
territoire en décembre dernier c'était
la marine ukrainienne qui affirmait que
des grenades comportant également cette
substance de chlorophysines avait été
utilisée contre ces troupes et c'est et
ce produit chimique et bien il a des
conséquences sur la santé je vous
propose d'écouter un médecin que j'ai
rencontré la semaine dernière tout près
de barmouth il explique les effets sur
la santé des patients blessés qu'il
reçoit
récemment la Russie a commencé à
utiliser des armes chimiques
c'est pourquoi on voit parfois des
soldats rivés chez nous avec des
symptômes des soufflements et
d'irritations des muqueuses des yeux de
l'euro pharynx
[Musique]
c'est une sorte de on ne sait pas encore
le plus exactement l'arme n'a pas encore
été entièrement étudié
mais on constate que des gaz
lacrymogènes sont utilisés
de la poudre jaune est utilisée
en tout cas nous n'avons pas encore
déterminé de quoi il s'agit
de quel type d'armes il s'agit mais ce
que nous pouvons dire c'est que ce type
d'armes chimique
a été utilisé à plusieurs reprises et ce
n'était pas le cas pendant les premiers
mois